what role does love play in this whole
thing in the in the human condition
in all the study of genocide it does
seem that
hardship
in moments brings out the best in human
nature and the best in human nature is
expressed through love
well as i already mentioned to you i
think
hardship can
is not a good thing
for for you know it's not the best thing
for love i mean it's better
it's better to not have to suffer and
not have to yes i think it is i think
it's you you know
as i mentioned to you you know
studying concentration camps you know
this is not a place for love it happens
it happens
but it's not really a place for love
it's a place for rape it's a place for
torture
it's a place for killing and this place
for
in human action one to another
you know and also as i said among those
who are suffering
not just between those who are
and and then there are whole gradations
you know the same thing in the gulag you
know they're gradations all the way from
the
the criminal prisoners who beat the hell
out of the political prisoners you know
who then have others below them who they
beat down you know so everybody's being
the hell out of everybody else so i
would i would not idealize in any way
suffering as a you know uh
a source of beauty a source of beauty
and love i wouldn't do it but i think
it's a whole lot better
for people to be relatively prosperous
i'm not saying super prosperous but to
be able to feed themselves and to be
able to feed their families
and house their families and take care
of
themselves
you know to foster
loving relations between people and um
you know i think it's no accident that
um you know poor families have much
you know worse
records when it comes to crime and
things like that you know and and also
to
wife beating and to
child abuse and stuff like that i mean
you just
you don't you don't want to be
poor and indigent and not have a roof
over your head be homeless i mean it
doesn't mean again
you know homeless people are are mean
people that's not what i'm trying to say
what i'm trying to say is that you know
what we want to try to foster in this
country and around the world
and one of the reasons you know
i mean
i'm very critical of the chinese in a
lot of ways but i mean we have to
remember they pulled that country out of
horrible poverty right and uh i mean
there's still poor people on the
countryside there's still problems you
know with with
want and need
among the chinese people but you know
there were millions and millions of
chinese who were living at the bare
minimum of life which is no way to live
you know and no way again to foster love
and compassion and and and getting along
so
i want to be clear i don't speak for
history right i i'm giving you
there used to be historians you know in
the 19th century who really thought they
were speaking for history yeah you know
i don't think that way at all i mean i
understand i'm a subjective human being
with my own
my own points of view and my own
opinions but i'm trying to remember this
in this conversation that you're just
despite the fact that you're brilliant
and you've written brilliant books that
you're just human
well with an opinion
that's it yeah no no that's absolutely
true and uh
i tell my students that too i mean i
make sure they understand this is not
history speaking you know this is me and
norman and i'm
you know and this is uh
this is what it's about i mean i spent a
long time studying history and and um
have enjoyed it
uh enormously but um you know i'm an
individual with my points of view and
one and one of them is that i've
developed over time
is that you know
you know human want is a real is a real
tragedy for people and and it hurts
people and it also causes upheavals and
difficulties and stuff like that
so i feel for people you know i feel for
people in syria i feel for people in in
you know in ethiopian tigre you know
when they don't have enough to eat and
you know what that does i mean it
doesn't mean they don't love each other
right and doesn't mean they don't love
their kids
but it does mean that it's harder you
know to do that and to and i'm not so
i'm not so sure it's obvious to me that
it's harder it's there's suffering
there's suffering but you the numbers
we've been talking about deaths been
talking about suffering but the numbers
were not quantifying the the history
that you haven't perhaps been looking at
is all the times that people have fallen
in love deeply with friends
with romantic love that the the the the
positive emotion that people have felt
and i'm not so sure
that amidst the suffering those moments
of beauty and love can't be discovered
and if we look at the numbers i'm not so
sure the story is obvious
there that
you know i mean again i i suppose you
may disagree with victor franco i'm 82
maybe depending on the day i mean he
says that if there's meaning to this
life at all there's meaning to the
suffering too because suffering is part
of life
there's something about
accepting
the ups and downs
even when the downs go very low and
within all of it
finding a source of meaning
i mean he's arguing from the perspective
of psychology but just
this life is an incredible gift almost
no matter what
and i'm not
it's easy to uh
look at suffering and think if we just
escape the suffering it will all be
better
but
we all die
there's beauty in the whole thing and
it is true that it's just
from all the stories i've read
especially in famine and starvation it's
just horrible
it is horrible suffering
but i i also just want to say that
there's love amidst it and we can't
forget that no no i don't i don't forget
it i don't forget it but and i think
it's from the stories now i don't want
to make that compromise or that trade
but the intensity of friendship and war
the intensity of love and war
is very high
so i'm not sure what to make of these
calculations but if you look at the
stories some of the people i'm closest
with and i've never experienced anything
even close to any of this but some of
the people i'm closest with is people
i've gone through difficult times with
there's something about that there
there's society or a group
where things are easy
the intensity of the connection between
human beings is not as strong i don't
know what to do with that calculus
because i too agree with you i want to
have as little suffering in the world as
possible
but we have to remember about the love
and the depth of human connection and
find the right balance there
i
no there's some there's something to
what you're saying there's clearly
something to what you're saying i was
just thinking about soviet union you
know when i lived there and
and people on the streets were so mean
to one another and they never smiled and
you grew up there yeah but you were
you're too young too no no i remember
well i came here when i was 13 yeah okay
so anyway um i remember living there and
just how hard people were on each other
on the streets and when you got inside
people's apartments when they
started to trust you you know the
friendships were so intense and so
wonderful
so in that sense i mean they did live a
hard life
but there was enough food on the table
and there was a roof over their head
there's a certain line there's a certain
there are lines you know i don't think
there's one line but you know it's kind
of a shading
and the other story i was thinking of as
you were talking was it's not a story
it's a
history history
a book um you know by a friend of mine
who wrote about
love in the um
camps
in the refugee camps for jews in germany
after the war
so these were jews who had come mostly
from poland and were you know some
survived the camps came from awful
circumstances
and then they were put in these camps
which were not joyful places i mean they
were guarded sometimes by germans even
but they're basically under the british
british control and they were trying to
get to israel you know trying to get to
palestine um
right after the war
and how many pairs there were how many
people coupled up but remember this is
after being in the constitution yes it's
not being in the concentration yes and
it's
also being free yes you know to
more or less free you know to express
their emotions and and to be
human beings after this horrible
thing which they suffered so i wonder
whether there's you know as you say some
kind of calculus there where you know
the the level of suffering is um
is such that uh it's just too much for
humans to bear and um
you know which i would suggest i mean i
haven't studied this myself i'm just
giving you my point of view you know my
off-the-cuff remarks here but it was
very inspiring to read about these
couples who had met right in these camps
and started to couple couple up you know
and and get married and
and try to find their way to palestine
which was a difficult thing to do then
you